hats off to anyone who has to deal with
acrylic nails i couldn't do anything
from cgi muscles to way too tight pants
and even a mouthful of black goop some
thor loving thunder prosthetics and
costumes were harder to bring to life
than they look so whose costume was the
most painful and whose actually wasn't
there at all
number one gore the godbutcher's nails
presented a handful of problems for the
actor christian bale a lot went into
making gore look like a super scary
villain fit for a fan favorite superhero
and some of course creepiest details are
the ones that made bale's life on set
the most difficult according to bale his
attire made him completely incapable of
everything and he cited gore's long
nails as the most difficult part of the
costume to deal with bale called himself
pathetic when trying to sport the
unusually long fingernails in his words
i don't think i can walk because i've
got long nails it affected my brain i
was like i can't eat i've got long nails
despite how difficult dealing with this
costume was it gave bale a newfound
understanding of folks who opt for
particularly decorative hands like gore
i couldn't eat i have a lot of respect
for anyone wearing long acrylic nails
now i couldn't do a damn thing with it
sounds like bale will be keeping the
nail clippers handy from now on
number two the nails weren't the only
part of gore's costume that caused bale
trouble he also had to spend a whole lot
of time in the makeup chair when you see
gore the god butcher it's hard to even
remember that christian bale is in there
somewhere bale is known for being able
to physically transform into different
characters but
gore certainly gave him a run for his
money to transform into the hair-raising
villain bale had to sit in the makeup
chair for three and a half hours every
day and according to him that was after
they shaped the routine down to be more
time efficient he said we got it down to
three and a half hours each morning
myself and three absolutely brilliant
makeup artists creating gore each and
every day between gore scars and spooky
white skin it's no wonder this took ages
number 3 the god of thunder himself got
dangerously close to ripping off his
super tight superhero pants how the
mighty have fallen in a less scary and
more hilarious wardrobe problem thor's
pants were so tight there was almost a
wardrobe malfunction of godlike
proportions thor love and thunder
costume designer mayas rubio paid
special attention to making sure that
thor had a more 80s rock look than his
normal superhero threads that's why she
costumed thor in a t-shirt that left
little to the imagination and pants so
tight that in rubio's words my
assistants were kind of worried there's
nothing that says rockstar quite like
the pants that are so tight it's
worrisome
number four jane's suit has some
aerodynamic details that the other suits
don't most of us watching superheroes on
screen have probably never thought about
how difficult it is for mere mortals to
sport their suits actors actually have
to go through training to learn how to
carry the suit since natalie portman
didn't have that training under her belt
rubio kept her suit on the lighter side
she made sure to use lighter fabrics
with more movement for jane's suit
compared to thor's and she also needed a
much shorter cape that didn't drag
behind 5'3 portman
number 5 if you thought christian bale
had been through enough with this gore
costume already think again it wasn't
easy getting those creepy black teeth in
fact it was downright gross in order to
make gore's mouth look black any pink of
the actual inside of bale's mouth needed
to be covered bale sported a pair of
fake teeth and they were covered with a
sticky substance that made his whole
mouth and tongue look black
number six you may have wondered about
how thor love and thunder brought thor's
hair back to its roots no pun intended
many fans were excited to see thor's
hair back in its og's state of long
flowing locks and if you're wondering if
chris hemsworth is actually blessed with
that head of hair or if it's a bit of
movie magic it looks like that mane is
all him while hemsworth allegedly donned
a wig for the first thor movie about a
year before thor love and thunder
premiered hemsworth posted an adorable
instagram showing him sparring with his
young son while already wearing thor's
long locks and a bun
number seven did you know that jane
foster's helmet wasn't actually there
natalie portman did have a helmet made
especially for her but this helmet was
only worn for her wardrobe fittings and
for photos when she actually filmed
scenes the helmet would have been a bit
too cumbersome to fight in so instead
the helmet was added in in
post-production even when we're looking
right at it we can't tell that that
helmet is cgi
number eight
speaking of natalie portman's superhero
attire her wardrobe was actually
entirely vegan portman is very adamant
about her beliefs and sticking to her
vegan lifestyle so as far as this star
is concerned wearing garments that
required animal cruelty to make are a
no-go according to costume designer
mayas rubio however this challenge was
no problem rubio says that there are
tons of incredible options for someone
looking for vegan textiles instead of
regular leather she went for leather
that was made from a cactus and
according to her it looks exactly like
the real thing number nine thor love and
thunder's main characters weren't the
only folks to get into seriously
intricate costumes and prosthetics and
sometimes it was the other characters
whose costumes presented the most
challenges rubio recalled one particular
costume in the omnipotent city scene
that required a ton of work according to
her she created a mosaic bodysuit for
the actor and then the makeup artist
recreated the design on his face he also
had a massive headpiece that she
hand-placed feathers on ultimately she
says you could only see him on screen
for two seconds but she was still very
proud of that outcome you've really
gotta have attention to detail like that
to make the mcu come alive
number 10 it's easy to forget that
impossible to notice stunt doubles means
double the costumes and when makeup and
costumes are as difficult to make as
they were for thor love and thunder it
means loads of extra work photos of
tessa thompson and her stunt double tara
mackin in their full valkyrie attire
show just how close these costumes are
they're so close in fact that you would
never notice a difference if you
couldn't see their faces and that's why
you almost certainly didn't notice two
valkyries while watching this movie
number 11 a lot went into turning 5-3
natalie portman into a 6-foot tall
superhero jane foster yes natalie
portman is actually on the shorter side
and her character jane is notoriously
tall so how did poorman go from being
the same height as co-star tessa
thompson two towering over her it turns
out she was always standing on a
platform which allowed her to be face to
face with her much taller co-star
hemsworth the more you know
number 12 many fans wonder how portman
got that buff to play jane foster height
wasn't the only major physical
difference between natalie portman and
her character jane portman's arms were
seriously muscular in this movie and
since behind the scenes images showing
portman's arms covered in
motioncapture.surface reddit exploded
with the rumor that jane foster's arms
were more cgi magic than muscle marvel
president kevin feige however insists
that there was no cgi added to portman's
biceps in fact portman worked five days
a week for 10 months working out and
pounding protein shakes to get majorly
bulked up did any of these costume
secrets surprise you what are you hoping
to see return in the next movie tell us
all your thoughts in the comments and
remember to like and subscribe to the
things for all the details on your
favorite tv and movie news
[Music]